Come on buddy wake up that's my man
you lose this again i'm keeping it
what happened you messed with
time it tends to mess back
you'll see one he's been talking
about the one that he's so afraid of
is kang. Kang is bent on destruction and
i'm so curious to see what jonathan does
in the future i think with he who remains the
the objective for me was to give me the largest
canvas possible and then from that as kang begins
to wear his head and do his deeds in so many ways
he has no choice but to be in opposition or
to be different from he who remains
Welcome back everyone you mess with time it tends to
mess back this is my video all about how iron
man probably knew about kang in his variants
this whole time given a lot of new details
that we've just uncovered on the loki's series
in what he who remains said about himself and
his variants across the multiverse all the other
kangs so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's even more multiverse craziness
coming up during my marvel what if episodes in a
couple weeks and careful for spoilers from loki
if you have not been watching those episodes a
lot of what they said about the history of kang
in the marvel universe during the series fills in
some really big gaps in questions from avengers
end game avengers infinity war doctor strange
marvel and kevin feige do that all the time
they'll always use brand new marvel projects to
sort of fill in the gaps and make earlier movies
seem even better in retrospect the way they also
used the loki episodes to make loki's journey in
all the previous marvel movies seem even more
meaningful but there's a lot of new evidence
now including some canonical tie-in book material
that expands on what iron man was talking about
when he discusses time travel in the
multiverse during avengers end game
there was a book that marvel published recently
called the wakanda files it's actually shuri's
notes the way that they write it dealing with all
kinds of minutia in really specific things from
all the marvel movies and characters for instance
it actually breaks down how much bucky barnes earn
that's how much detail that it gets into
if you're a fan of that kind of stuff
for the purposes of this video i'm just going to
be referencing what it reveals about iron man in
his time travel research during avengers end
game and what he learned about the multiverse
during that how it explains him knowing about
the existence of the sacred timeline and kang
so during avengers end game iron man is the one
who discovers a safe way to travel through time
using the quantum realm pym particles quantum
energy building on hank pym's research given to
him by scott lang previously in the movie ant-man
the hulk black widow captain america had attempted
time travel without iron man's help to hilarious
consequences so there were people time traveling
before iron man and even during the loki series we
can see the tva arresting a woman from what looks
like the 1940s or 1950s in sorry for anyone that
thought that this was a peggy carter variant the
director of loki did an interview recently where
she debunked that theory she said that she loved
all the theories that people were coming up with
during the series but this woman was not meant to
be peggy carter she was just a random woman from
the past that was there to show you that there
were people creating nexus events and traveling
through time long before the avengers did during
end game like this is meant to be happening
all across the timeline past present and future
iron man is just one of the first people that
we know about right now to figure out how to
time travel reliably and safely travel through
time then be able to come back to the moment in
time where you left from on purpose so when he
was doing his research figuring out how to crack
time travel correctly the wakanda files contain
a note that he wrote to the hulk speaking about
the deutsche model of quantum mechanics which is
a real life thing david deutsch's model is all
about the existence of parallel universes which is
what kang was talking about when he explained his
backstory is nathaniel richards and how he also
discovered parallel universes stacked on top of
his own when he was in the 31st century but in
his note to the hook iron man states altering
the events of the past could never affect the
continuous loop remember that term though it
could create tangential split timelines let's not
worry about that for the time being earlier in
the movie when ant-man and the other avengers are
trying to win him over he also mentions triggering
the deutsche proposition tony after everything
you've seen is anything really quantum fluctuation
messes with a plank scale which then triggers
the deutsche proposition can we agree on that
in layman's terms it means you're not coming home
so when he says they might theoretically trigger
the deutsche proposition he's saying they could
create alternate branch realities nexus events
as they call them on loki which would lead to
parallel universes rising up but also in his
note to the hulk when iron man talks about the
continuous loop he's referencing the concept
of the sacred timeline even though he doesn't
call it that he who remains just called it the
sacred timeline is part of this whole thing
with the official tva dogma that's what he
was joking about with loki and sylvie when he was
making those ah men prayers while explaining the
creation of the tva to manage his isolated
timeline he also shows a depiction of that
as a loop around itself at the beginning of the
episode you also see the sacred timeline itself
curving around the citadel at the end of time on
that asteroid that whole concept of the continuous
loop is also part of what he's talking about
when he speaks to sylvie about resurrection
the timeline will start again he'll be born
nathaniel richards again in the 31st century
and everything will play out in a relatively
similar way and that's why he says they will
also eventually wind up right back in this
room you plunge your blade in my chest and an
infinite amount would be start another multiversal
war and i just end up right back here anyways
also notice during avengers end game when iron
man is cracking time travel you see him examining
this mobius strip and you see the lines of
energy arcing around it in a continuous loop
does that not look like a representation of the
sacred timeline with all the interwoven strands
if it weren't clear when you're looking at the
actual sacred timeline those interwoven strands
are meant to represent the multiverse as it
existed before loki and silvi mess things up
unleashing all of kang's variants in the
much larger true version of the multiverse
the sacred timeline is kind of like a rope of time
a large rope made from many smaller pieces of rope
interwoven together itches that he who remains
only allowed alternate universes to exist that
didn't lead to bad versions of kang rising up so
before the loki finale there was a multiverse it
was just a much smaller version of the multiverse
and given iron man's comments to the hulk on the
dangers of alternate universes time messing back
with them he essentially predicted what became
kang's multiverse war even though he might not
have known kang's name he predicted that creating
a lot of these branch timelines could lead to
a situation where they wind up fighting people
across different universes it's easier to
understand if you think about iron man as a
worst case scenario kind of person they dealt with
that during avengers age of ultron like ultron is
the result of him going overboard because of
his worst case scenarios we're the avengers
we can bust arms dealers all the live long day
but that up there that's that's the end game
how were you guys planning on beating that but if
you thought that there was only a loose connection
between kang and iron man before the loki series
like everybody watches that avengers end game
scene and says you know what he's probably
talking about king right there think about
some of these newer easter eggs and references
from the loki series that connect them even more
so most of kang's technology that he used when
he first started exploring alternate universes
met his first variant was probably based on iron
man's time travel platform technology nathaniel
richards actually started out as a historian in
the 31st century before he became a scientist
he had a fascination with the past inside he who
remains study you can actually see artifacts that
he collected from all across the entire timeline
zoom and enhanced in the background you can even
see that he's got one of iron man's helmets on
his shelves but you don't really spot any other
artifacts from the other avengers this study
is meant to be where he keeps his most prized
possessions kang's temp pad here that he wears
on his wrist and plays with during the episode
pre-programmed with a bunch of coordinates for
space and time to move him around not only does
the design language look almost the exact same it
functions the exact same way that iron man's wrist
devices do those wrist devices that they were
all wearing during endgame were pre-programmed
with all the time space coordinates for their
jumps and be able to automatically come back
to the time travel platform in present day he who
remains just seems like he took that technology in
the 31st century and refined it a little bit more
and that's also probably one of the reasons why he
allowed the avengers to have a complete free pass
traveling through time stealing infinity stones
when loki got arrested for stealing the tesseract
according to rensslayer he who remains said that
the avengers were supposed to do everything that
they did if he who remains is so powerful that
he can change whatever he wants about loki and
sylvia's lives like giving loki the infinity
gauntlet and letting him do whatever he wants
to with it and it's no big deal why is it so
important that the avengers perform their time
heist when he who remains could have just gone
back and defeated thanos himself if he wanted it's
pretty clear that he who remains thinks of thanos
as kind of a joke in the grand cosmic scheme of
things if he's responsible for writing all the tba
dogma there's actually a test that loki is taking
during episode two if you look at this computer
here it uses thanos in this example of avengers
end game time travel rules about thanos trying
to steal apples from the past it's just a funny
exploration of the time travel logic from avengers
end game using thanos and apples so no coincidence
that in the future he who remains is sitting there
eating an apple when he's talking to loki and
sylvie he who remains showing just how powerful
he actually is so why then didn't he just take
care of thanos himself why would he allow all that
to play out well the reason is probably because
if the avengers had never done their time heist
iron man wouldn't have invented his time travel
platform and he who remains would never been able
to use it in the future to explore other alternate
universes he would have never wound up becoming
he who remains he would never have been able to
stop his variants from destroying his timeline his
universe so that's probably the real reason the
avengers got a free pass because he needed them
to do that so that iron man would create this
time travel platform so that he could become
who he needed to become to win the multiverse
war this stuff it needs to happen to finish
the quest but with the way he who remains
talks about having paved the road for all these
characters so to speak orchestrated the sacred
timeline so that everyone is doing everything
that he wants them to do and clipping the things
that he doesn't want them to do iron man seems
like he learned about a lot of this during his
time travel research that he would have become
aware of the threat of a person or variance in
the future doing all these things now he might not
have known kang's name or he who remains name he
just probably knew that there was someone looming
over all this the whole time for all time always
and across countless other alternate realities
and kang being so obsessed with iron man enough
to keep his armor in his private study with his
most personal possessions makes it sound like
he did have a special extra connection to him
more so than a lot of other historical figures
there's even a younger version of kang in the
comics that also sets himself up in the past as
iron lad inspired by iron man trying to avoid
his future fate as a villain trying to be a better
version of kang a better variant but let me know
in the comments how much about kang his variance
the multiverse war do you think that iron man
predicted accurately and do you think that kang
needed iron man to create his time travel platform
so that he could crib from it in the future this
is only the beginning of the marvel multiverse we
have marvel what if episodes starting in a couple
weeks i will be doing all those episodes make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss any of that i've got a lot of fun stuff
planned for that in the meantime everyone click
here to learn where the marvel netflix daredevil
characters are coming back in the mcu and click
here for that loki season 2 teaser and more kang
deleted scenes thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!